okay
we're back i'm so pumpy i know i'm
sending you a really big hug
honey because i was like oh idol's
probably gonna be the last time i'll
talk to her before she has the baby but
no
here we are no i'm at that place where i
feel
like i have been pregnant i actually
said to my doctor
um well now i'm 58 weeks pregnant and
i didn't mean it i was like i thought i
was 58
he's pregnant um and everyone had a
laugh
um but yeah i feel like i have been
pregnant forever but people forget you
have to cook a baby for 10 months
exactly people get it straight and yeah
yes but you look radiant and ever so
fashionable
uh just your true katy perry self i feel
like it i mean really you've been
rocking crop tops girl
look at your your your headpiece that
you got on today
the daisies of darling i'm still trying
i'm still
working i'm it's nice to be able to um
you know not look at the hands of time
roll by and i'm so
excited for both deliveries both
obviously the child and obviously the
record
and yeah it's you know i think 2020
may have a silver lining for me yeah
i think it it does it gives you
definitely reason to smile
and speaking about it
and look at that album cover i love it
so
good but here you are smiling you're
finally able to put out this album
to the world it must feel great because
you did have to delay it due to the
pandemic
yeah i mean i think anyone that's made
plans
in 2020 has had to do a little bit of
the pivot dance
and really i think it's about going with
the flow and this year
is somewhat about surrender and i know
in my personal life i'm gonna have to
surrender
and it's definitely you know bled it
over into my
uh professional life and i'm just
grateful that i get to do it
this summer it's a summer record it's
full of hopefulness
it's full of light and joy and
it's not just you know taking up space
and noise
[Music]
i hope that uh these songs which i wrote
you know going through one of the
darkest times in my life
could be inspirational to anyone else
that's going through
whatever they're going through because
music has always been that for me
so i know i feel like at times you just
break it down and it's raw
and then other times it's like about
love sometimes you just want to like jam
in the middle of the club
i feel like you go through all sorts of
emotions not a lot of ballads on this
there's maybe one ballad actually it's
um
kind of a mid-tempo it ends the record
it's called what makes a woman
um so yes it's an up up
it's a you know it's a serotonin for the
ears moment
it most definitely is girl so it must be
it must be feeling so great for you
to get this out there and i feel like
this has been the busiest i feel like i
have ever seen you
we've seen you kick off space launches
we've seen you
you know get the vote out there or
encourage people to vote we see you on
idle you're releasing an
album and you're birthing a child mama
i mean i mean yeah like respect
women we can do it all oh
we can't but are you planning on
settling down and slowing down at all
you and orlando before you give birth to
your daughter
i think so i think i'll have to i think
just
physically i'm holding on to the
railings of stairs a lot harder than i
was
um but yeah no i know that it's all
gonna come to a screeching halt
uh very very soon so i'm kind of packing
it in
as much as i can but um you know i
i think a lot of the heavy lifting
figuratively goes before the record and
then the record comes out
and people just enjoy the record um
and yeah i mean i don't know who's going
to come first her or the record we'll
see
what kind of headlines she wants she
wants uh she wants to be the opener or
the closer
i have a feeling she does not follow you
know she might
i don't know but i don't know how she
sees it it's gonna be so good
nonetheless
now i must remind you so this album
drops august 28th
now a few days before august 24th you'll
be celebrating
the 10th anniversary of teenage dreams
your iconic album so when you think back
on teenage dream tell me darling
what do you think and you're do i look
10 years older
no time has been very good to you
um time and doctors um
no i'm excited for the record to come
out
for smile to come out around the same
type of
uh energy as of teenage dream of course
that was a different time it was 10
years ago
and the whole world has changed most
definitely
um but you have changed because i feel
like
we still have these empowering hopeful
songs on smile
we had them obviously on teenage dreams
with firework and
teenage dream and but how do you feel
like you yourself
have evolved musically personally
yeah i mean personally i think everyone
changes from their 20s to their 30s
oh yes um whether you like it or not
it's almost like you know the ideas that
you had about yourself when you were
a young teenager like 14 15 16 and you
were so
dead set about them they changed when
you turned 21 22 23 it's just
that's the growth um which is great
i think that i'm so proud of everything
that i've been able to put out and i
love it and i love that
you know teenage dream became like a
real cool
marker for numbers or whatever
but i definitely don't live in that
headspace
anymore and have you know a little bit
more
dimension and life and
you know i'm experiencing all of it like
i'm not
just on the uh pop star rodeo
but you know i i like i like jumping on
and then jumping off every once in a
while
and making that pop star rodeo your own
yes
man pop star rodeo is my own i'm so
happy
for it it sure is now you're giving
birth to this album giving birth to your
daughter of course as we've mentioned
uh what do you look forward to most
about raising your daughter
um i look forward to well first and
foremost
you know it's an interesting thought to
have like that there's
finally one thing in your life that like
you can't just
set aside or turn off or decide that
today is not the day you're gonna deal
with it so that's like
that's that's most both comforting and
knowing that there's that forever anchor
and it's probably a little like scary
you know to go oh well this is a commit
this is the commitment of the life
you know um forever forever ever ever
um but there's beauty in that because
you know
it's like unconditional love and i'm
just excited to be able to
um you know raise her
in a different way that i was raised and
to
um let her think for herself and have
choice and you know
discover and just you know just lean
into the magic of life and and
and probably you know dress what like
whatever she wants
to dress like for halloween that's going
to be really really important i was
never allowed to go trick-or-treating
or no or dressing up that's probably why
i make up for it so much
yeah um i was in church girl you know
all about it
i do i do so but no but i mean i'm
excited
i'm gonna just we're here to support her
and
um you know a lot of people have asked
me are you gonna like
go away or whatever and i'm like i mean
doesn't beyonce have like three kids and
she's
still putting out black as king you know
like she's doing the best she
her whole life is amazing i don't feel
like you have to
choose between what you love and what
you love and for me this doesn't feel
like work it feels like
just you know something that really
makes me happy and i would hope that
my happiness is her happiness and her
happiness is my happiness
i love that katie ears blossomed into
this
incredible woman and incredible mom to
be and it's exciting to see you on this
journey and of course it's been exciting
for fans to see you on the journey
of american idol will we be seeing you
in season four of american idol
yes ma'am you will i'm excited i mean
it's
you know it's uh we're gonna have to go
with the flow this year because
just 20 20. you know we start shooting
again in the fall we'll see what that
looks like
but hopefully we can get more eye to eye
in
in 2021 let's all hope